pop ce que le voyez là n'est pas une
ville favre a une vraie vie des
universités toutes les images de sport
drop plein air comme des reines au
chômage ont été tournées à l'intérieur
de l'immense campus de stanford
le losc en forme milliardaire fondé
cette université parce que son fils mort
à 15 ans
pourrait jamais faire des coups à
l'époque de mégalo aujourd'hui il est
cool c'est grand
quelle forme de palmier akalitus plus
longue que de 13 mille étudiants venus
d'une centaine de pays d'afrique noire
on voudrait en accueillir plus en
revanche pour beaucoup d'asiatiques
pourra-t-il un jour en limiter l'onu
quelques dizaines de français dans les
hits scientifique et puis michel serres
philosophe qui entre dans le bâtiment
départements français quand ils faire ce
boulot
[Musique]
thème de ces conférences le temps mais
il y a tant et tant nous voici parvenus
au terme des conférences de ce printemps
vous savez que l on commençait sous le
titre le temps de la terre et marc
guillou a distribué deux photocopies qui
représente la globalité du sujet le
sujet terminal ce vers quoi je me dirige
depuis déjà cinq semaines
l'une de ces photocopies représente ce
qu'on est convenu d'appeler la
mappemonde politique et la deuxième
photo copie représente le globe
terrestre
disons le globe terrestre photographiée
par satellite
première remarque il doit exister dans
l'espace autant de points de vue qu'on
veut à partir duquel on peut
photographier cet objet concret réel
qu'est la terre alors qu' on ne peut pas
imaginer qu'ils puissent exister un
point de vue concret à partir d'où on
pourrait photographier la mappemonde
politique personnes voyageant en avion
ne peut percevoir par le hublot ni
l'équateur ni le cercle polaire ni les
méridiens ni les parallèles ni a
fortiori les frontières entre les
nations faut-il alors conclure que cette
photographie est celle d'un objet réel
et concret et que l'autre est simplement
une représentation abstraite pas tout à
fait en effet quoi de plus tragiquement
concret que les guerres du décide des
frontières des empires
quoi de plus tragiquement concret que la
naissance ou l'effondrement des royaumes
quoi de plus concret que la fortune et
la misère des nations représentent est
là dans l'amap man 2 de type politique
donc cette maman de 20 et elle varie
comment s'est elle varie selon le temps
quel temps le temps qui passe le temps
que nous battons al'inverse jusqu'à la
naissance du christ et à partir d'un
compte positif
depuis l'année zéro jusqu'à nos jours il
existe donc un temps qu en anglais vous
appelez times
mais le second objet celui de la
deuxième photo copie varie aussi et ils
varient commandes ce qui varie c'est le
temps mais non point dans le premier
sens de time mais au sens du wave heures
le premier est une mappemonde selon le
premier sens du temps la deuxième est
une photocopie ou une photographie
selon le 2e temps sens du temps tang qui
coule pour la carte temps qu'il fait
pour le globe terrestre
quel est le rapport qu'il existe entre
ces deux temps c'était le sujet de mon
cours et je voudrais conclure
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
c'est dans ces superbes villas l'intérêt
euloge les professeurs
en règle générale elle leur appartient
m
les ventes à leurs successeurs les
piscines sont derrière
dép rené girard
l'auteur de des choses cachées depuis la
fondation mozilla sa vie à 7
il est comme tout le monde ici bien sûr
son vélo mais contrairement à michel
serres provisions français deux fois par
an en californie
rené girard est un prof franco-américain
à demeure astaffort
vous avez choisi les états unis en
quelle année à peu près 1947 et vous
êtes à standford depuis quelques années
1980 oui alors entre 40 et 80 vous avez
fait des universités 57,80 oui j'étais à
l'université d'état de gt pendant des
années à l'université johns hopkins de
baltimore
j'étais en caroline du nord à duke
universités
j'étais dans un collège de jeunes filles
à près de philadelphie à l'université de
new york à buffalo et vous donnez
combien d'heures de cours par semaine à
savary mai j'enseigne deux trimestres ou
trois par an c'est-à-dire six mois ou 9
mois et je fais deux cours par semaine à
ces moments là de deux heures chacun
cela nous laisse du temps pour vos
travaux personnels beaucoup dé temps et
donc là vous pouvez écrire oui c'est ça
au livre très bien et donc vous avez
quittez pourquoi avez vous quitté la
france si longtemps maintenant vous êtes
signaux et américains j'ai les deux
citoyenneté je suis citoyen américain
est citoyen français de mariée
l'américaine vous avez marié les enfants
américaine des enfants américains en
inde et des arbres qui sont tous
bilingues et c'est un gros travail je
vous assure que de rendre des enfants
bilingues aux états-unis - difficile
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui qui a une
trentaine mais est ce que pour les
français qui vous connaissait notamment
les français d'avignon puisque vous êtes
d'avignon est ce que vous n'avez pas été
considérées d'une certaine manière comme
un traître ont peut-être un peu par
certains
écoutez ou ceux qui ne considèrent comme
un traître de me le disent pas être
attirées ctte mans mais ça vous croyez
qu aujourd'hui on peut être traître
non mais il ya 40 ans si il ya 40 ans
peut-être oui
en 40 ans oui en fait il ne me l'a pas
dit lui même mais parmi mes premières
connaissances littéraires il ya les rené
char est paraît-il rené char a critiqué
pensé qu'il ne fallait pas partir aux
états unis mais il ya donc deux hommes
il ya le français et puis américaine
évidemment ces deux hommes
si ces deux hommes évidemment fonds rené
girard mais est ce que ces deux hommes
parfois ne s'oppose pas l'un à l'autre
non vraiment pas parce que pour moi
l'amérique essentiellement c'est c'est
le système universitaire et le système
universitaire ici est tellement
cosmopolite tellement internationale le
corail âge qu'il ne pèse jamais où il
vous permet d'être totalement français
dans votre carrière
mais parce que moi ma carrière
littéraire si l'on peut dire enfin ma
carrière qui n'est pas une carrière
d'érudits m'aider céiste s'est déroulée
à peu près totalement en france je
publie les articles si on fait des
offres aux états unis dans l'egypte des
artistes à cause de ce que j'ai publié
en france ce qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire
mais si j'étais un allemand ça se
passerait de la manière avec francfort
berlin et les maisons d'édition
si je vous entends bien ça veut dire que
vous avez c'est parce que vous avez
publié des livres en français publié les
articles en france que les américains au
fond vous en découvert alors que vous
viviez déjà chez eux
voilà voilà c'est ça autrement b c la
france y la langue française qui vous en
donner ce lustre ce bien sûr bien sûr je
me sens totalement français que c'est
trop de mécanique qui sont les vôtres
je pense que l'amérique bien comprise
vous enseigne à être européen et
français
elle a plein
[Musique]
il bosse dur d'un ordinateur en veux tu
en voilà
il est aussi facile d'accès mon seul
ordinateur que d'emprunter un stylo à
bille et puis alors étonnant fascinant
extravagantes plusieurs dizaines de
statue de rodin dont les bourgeois de
calais dont la porte de l'enfer et puis
tant d'autres shannon dans un jardin du
campus magnifique et dans un musée
attenant d'erding foison je vous dis et
les filles on retrouve sa voiture elle
appartient tous appartient à
l'université qui comme vous le savez est
une des universités des prises
pas tout à fait la plus riche et la
deuxième ou troisième main forte
le capital de stanford est évalué à un
peu plus d'un milliard de dollars je
dirais volontiers que la différence qu
on pourrait noter sur ce point ce point
de la richesse entre eux l'amérique et
la france où plus de l'europe sexuelle
en amérique on fait de l'argent avec
quelque chose l'argent est un but et la
chose est un moyen la chose c'est-à-dire
avec de la terre des bâtiments de
l'informatique de l'industrie de la
recherche et la chose est un moyen et
l'argent et un but
je dirais volontiers qu en europe ce
serait presque l' inverse
l'argent est un moyen et la chose et un
but avec de l'argent on a le souci de
faire des choses de sorte que dans le
cas de réussite et je crois que
l'amérique a parfaitement réussi
l'amérique a beaucoup d'argent et elle
est un peu vide de choses tandis que
l'europe a plus d'argent mais elle est
beaucoup plus pauvres elle est plein de
choses et voilà la preuve tu n'aimes
c'est à dire les choses dont nous sommes
entourés sur des choses pour auxerre
c'est étonnant ce qui est stupéfiant et
sur ses campus de stanford c'est que
c'est que c'est une ville l'héritier ya
l'air et à la poste avec les boîtes
postales la prochaine chaque étudiant
c'est une litote exactement le lion
total c'est pour oui c'est une ville
complète avec ses services ses commerces
où ça s'approche tout sa bibliothèque
cris et même sa production parce que
chaque département de l'université
rapporte de l'argent à l'université en
passant des contrats avec des industries
privées alors ce qui ce qui a encore
marqué c'est que au centre du campus
c'est pas ça a été fait exprès il y à
l'habilité disons les bibliothèques
littéraire et l'église et les vamps
allons d'abord d'un médiateur
les bibliothèques sont le centre de
l'inertie et on ne pourra jamais assez
faire l'éloge du biotech américaine
elles sont parfaitement organisées elles
sont généralement très riche et très
libérale on peut y entrer accéder au
rayon et lorsque j'étais jeune et que je
suis arrivé il ya 20 ans aux états unis
je disais ma femme je suis un chat
maigre à qui on a proposé en poulets
rôtis entier pour un chercheur c'est le
paradis c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux dans
les universités moi ce qui m'a frappé en
évitant ces bibliothèques c'est l'accès
immédiat ou immédiat et est en plus la
gratuité jean rentrée un étudiant
français qui a fait les photocopies
pendant deux mois il a fait des
photocopies de ces à tout ce qu'il me
désirait gratuitement pour pas un sou et
m'a dit ça m'aurait coûté en france
d'abord beaucoup de temps probablement
plusieurs mois plusieurs mois et
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
voilà les milieux tech sont très pauvres
en france ça c'est vrai et l'amérique
accrue aux livres elle a cru au savoir
et elle a mis son investissement majeur
dans l'humour c'est dans la bibliothèque
vous avez non seulement la possibilité
de fernand sastre copie et cetera mais
on peut presque y vivre on a un bureau
en particulier le bureau et dans le
rayon de votre spécialité
il ya des endroits où dormir les
endroits on peut écouter de la musique
on peut consulter des journaux est au
centre de la ville il ya aussi l'église
et j'ai été frappé de voir le
l'assistance très nombreuse de jeunes
il ya des jeunes ici à l'office du
dimanche à l'office catholique
c'est exact
au compteur
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a depuis quelques
années au d'ailleurs aussi bien en
europe qu'aux états unis
une reprise de la pratique religieuse
chez les jeunes c'est assez frappant et
c'est assez marqué et il ya encore une
différence ici très remarquable c'est
qu'avec le système de séparation de
l'église et de l'état
l'université française est parfaitement
coupé de la chose religieuse
cet environnement c'est une pas la
théologie on n'enseigne pas ce que les
américains appellent divinité un disque
au contraire aux états unis même en
angleterre
l'enseignement de la théologie de
l'histoire des religions et même la
pratique religieuse est inséré à
l'intérieur de l'université
quand nous sommes arrivés ici nous avons
eu la chance d'assister à une
représentation d'un groupe de rock
qualifié de soixante huitarde hui parce
que c'est ça c'est à dire que le la
révolution 68 a été mondiale comme vous
le savez et elle a eu qu un de ses
points d'origine a été bernée qui est
une université qui se trouve en face de
nous d'autres t de la baie et qui est
resté deux traditions soixante huitard
et vous avez vu que ces bruits et fred
qui est une coupe d'europe est composée
de gens qui a une faim comme celles
d'allier et que les étudiants actuels
considère en tant que vous anciens
combattants
max
[Musique]
il ya une fidélité peut-être l'un
n'empeche qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens
diversité et qui étaient là qui se
déhanchait au rythme des au rythme de
lors de leur part qu'ils aient
l'université est une ville et par
conséquent ils y allaient commerce il ya
les services mais aussi des spectacles
ya du théâtre du cinéma et d'autres
concerts classiques et les consciences
non
hélas
chaque année cette monnaie
soir alors maintenant revenons-en
évidemment à la question essentielle à
laquelle vous attendent évidemment
michel ça c'est que vous êtes professeur
à la sorbonne universités d'état
français et vous êtes professeur donc à
salford dans une université privée
américaine cct vous êtes à même de nous
dire quels sont les avantages et
inconvénients des deux systèmes
d'abord si je suis venue ici c'est pour
deux ou trois raisons d'abord des
raisons de hasard ou circonstancielle 1
un professeur américain liens de vos
livres et vous invite vous acceptez et
donc ça fait à peu près 20 ans que je
suis ici ça c'est des raisons de hasard
il ya des raisons plus profondes d'abord
c'est que la recherche scientifique
aussi bien littéraire de sa vente se
mondialise et par conséquent il est très
difficile pour un chercheur de rester
dans son enceinte patrie d'origine
il faut il voyage il se trouve que
j'aime beaucoup les voyages et que de la
même façon que j'aime le monde de ces
allergènes par des océans la banquise
des volcans de montagne etc
je voyage aussi dans les savoirs de lire
un philosophe doit passer par les
sciences visite les sciences comme ils
visitent le monde
et troisièmement il y à un effort à
faire c'est que la philosophie c'est la
citoyenneté du monde ici vous êtes dans
une ville venez de dire et cette ville
n'est pas forcément une ville américaine
je rencontre ici des italiens des belges
défini talent des japonais des
australiens et il y as je crois peu près
100 nationalités représentées ici donc
c'est une ville mondiale
la philosophie le philosophe doit faire
un troisième voyage dans les cultures
doit se fondre de plus en plus je suis
français de langue méridionale et il
faut faire l'effort de venir une autre
religion une autre culture une autre
langue devenir réellement aux citoyens
du monde qui n'est ce pas
rappelez dans jules verne le commandant
du sous marin s'est incliné mot sur
personne et cela renouer avec la vieille
tradition grecque de l'odyssée d'ulysse
à un moment s'appelle personnes et à
force de voyager dans le savoir dans le
monde et dans les cultures
vous savez vous appelez bernard pivot je
doute parfois que ce qu'on appelle des
chercheurs je deviens personnes c'est à
dire je me fonds dans la différence des
cultures et et j'aime autant l'italie
que le japon que l'inde voyez ce que fit
wii mais à mesure que je deviens
personnes
c'est à dire que le sujet de la pensée
philosophique devient universelle
je deviens de plus en plus particulier
et je crois de plus en plus à la langue
française au style particulier de la
france lire j'exporte ici toutes les
valeurs en universalisant en rentrant en
me fondant dans la totalité des des
cultures à mesure que je vieillis je
reviens vers ma propre particularité jeu
la sculpte avec le plus de singularité
possible je crois à cette espèce
d'équilibré entre eux la la la
singularité d'un style et d'une attitude
et l'universalité que j'apprends ici et
que je donne en même temps voilà bel
éloge de la singularité et universalité
du savoir mais vous n'avez pas répondu à
ma question c'est à dire quels sont les
avantages et inconvénients des deux
systèmes français et américains de
l'université proment dit qu'est ce que
cette fois nous apporte que vous ne
trouvez pas à briller à sorbonne et
qu'est ce que la sans voix nous apporte
que vous ne trouvez pas ici alors ce
type ce que ce que m'apporte exercice 5
source est essentiellement deux choses
d'abord à mon astuce vous avez remarqué
qu'ici il y emploie 1 classe et en
classe alors c'est une ville mais c'est
également au monastère savoir que tout
est fait pour la recherche les
bibliothèques le calme les bureaux etc
et par conséquent je travaille
incontestablement mieux ici parce que je
suis fermé
hall et que je suis un travailleur
immigré alors le travailleur immigré
tout seul il est tout seul avec d'autres
immigrés par conséquent ici je travaille
mieux incontestablement
l'inconvénient c'est que comme le campus
est fermé il est séparé de la vie
courante alors l'avantagent à paris
c'est que la sorbonne et en plongée dans
la ville de paris les étudiants en nous
voyons moins les étudiants nous vivons
moins avec les étudiants mais ils sont
immédiatement mêlée à la vie courante à
la rue au commerce et ainsi de suite
alors il faut jouer il faut jouer ou la
séparation ou la présente est pas et
plus je vieillis plus je trouve que les
systèmes d'enseignement au fond c'est
qu'ils valent c'est à dire que les
forces et les faiblesses ne sont pas au
même endroit mais il ya partout des
forces extérieures
vous savez on dit beaucoup de mal en
france de l'université prochain elle
n'est pas si mauvaise que du point de
vue de la qualité au fond des choses
c'est qu'ils valent et que l'europe en
ce moment a pris un très bon virage au
point de vue scientifique cherchait nos
services
ce qui est aussi quand même stupéfiant
pour les français c'est le prix
une année universitaire rob ford c'est
très cher et si j'ai calculé ça revient
donc pour un étudiant une paye plein pot
ça revient à dix mille francs par mois à
peu près c'est à dire que celui qui paie
la triche c'est à dire les inscriptions
l'inscription est évalué à peu près à 15
mille dollars par année et sur quatre
années ce qui revient à 60 mille dollars
était qu' on s'inscrit ici qu'il faut
faire la preuve qu'on pourra payer
pendant les 4 à 10 cependant la majorité
des étudiants gradués bénéficient d'une
bourse
c'est d'ailleurs celui qui paie paix à
la fois pour lui et aussi pour ceux qui
reçoivent la bourse
alors il ya une sorte de péréquation qui
rétablit un peu la justice les riches
payent d'une certaine manière par je
viens d'arrêter les études des pauvres
c'est ça en partie a fait des pauvres
des méritants les mairies vallée il ya
une sélection à l'entrée est et les
boursiers sont évidemment sélectionnés
sur 10 tandis qu'en france le système
est un peu différent premièrement il est
gratuit
et deuxièmement il n'y a pas de
sélection à l'entrée de l'université
alors du groupe
la sélection se fait le long des années
c'est à dire on élimine légende selon
les examens ou les concours et ici on
sélectionne au départ et l'étudiant à
plus de calme dans l'ensemble ses études
c'est à dire il n'est pas sélectionné
année par année
mais imaginons ce levier nre une vie
deuxième but vous choisiriez quelle quel
pays pour faire vos études à cet
immeuble est rayé à la sorbonne à nous
renier dryats standford ce qu'il fallait
et je crois que si j'avais une seconde
vie je ferai ce que j'ai fait dans la
première vie c'est à dire que
l'essentiel n'est pas d'être dans une
université l'essentiel je crois est
d'aller d'une université à l'autre et je
reprends le thème du voyage
d'ailleurs je crois qu'un philosophe
qu'un chercheur est un voyageur il doit
voyager il doit connaître
ce sciences de supprimer attention quand
vous êtes quand vous avez 15 ans vous
n'êtes pas encore un philosophe c'est
certain mais si j'avais un conseil à
donner aussi bien aux américains qu'aux
français c'est d'aller apprendre et
d'aller étudier dans le plus de pays et
d'universités aussi parce que au fond je
peux bien vous faire une confidence j'ai
un jeu poursuit un idéal comme tout le
monde et je crois que à force de voyager
de voir des gens différents des sciences
différente des cultures différentes
je désire profondément la tête par le
savoir c'est à dire que ces villages
mondiaux prépare peut-être un monde où
on aura la paix par la cia encore la
guerre par la science la guerre des
cultures la guerre des langues est ce
que je désire passionnément est-ce que
vous pourrez préparer à la fois dans les
livres dans mon enseignement c'est la
paix para nord
[Musique]
cet avenant
professeur de français spécialiste du
xviiie siècle français l'élève de girard
et de sel
excellentes capacités plus cela
commençait à l'université je prenais
plus de cours de littérature française
et j'étais passionné par le neveu de
rameau et j'ai décidé que ce siècle me
convenait en fallait que j'aie
réconcilient en même temps cette passion
que j'avais pour diderot avec une époque
qui n'est pas toujours très réjouissante
c'est l'époque de la raison est alors
dans votre livre séduit ou la passion
des lumières qui est publié aux éditions
méridiens klincksieck vous faites du
xviiie siècle non pas un siècle de la
raison des lumières mais ainsi que tout
à fait étrange puisque vous montrer un
site habité par des êtres nocturne par
des séductrices du cif et rienne par des
personnages un peu pervers pourquoi ce
qui me passionnait dans le roman du
xviiie siècle c'est justement ce double
aspect enfin que le roman traduisait à
mon avis une une schizophrénie à
l'intérieur du xviiie d'un côté
effectivement ce qu'on connaît du 18e
c'est la rationalité celle cancon
divulguer les philosophes et de l'autre
il y à une sorte de souterrains qui est
habitée par les puissance du désir est
que nous retrouvons dans le libertinage
il fallait que je convertissent en
quelque sorte dans mon étude sur le
roman du xviiie siècle
cette technologie du désir qu'on a
appelée libertinage ou la galanterie et
2 et de voir comment le mal du désir en
quelque sorte pénètre sous septe oui
mais quand on vole et on s'aperçoit
qu'au xviiie la galanterie la séduction
c'est l'enfer c'est exactement cela
7 ce désir effréné qu'on sait qu'on est
con les personnages je confesse être
pour l'autre et 7 foudroiement qu'ils
ont devant devant le désir de l'autre
robert a reason vous êtes prophète
américain vous êtes professeur de langue
et de littérature italienne ici à
stanford
mais vous allez devenir aussi professeur
de langue et de littérature françaises
ce qui est quand même un exploit
et pourquoi jouer sur les deux tableaux
sur les deux langues sur les deux
littérature mais pour une raison très
simple
je suis arrivé ici à 4 ans j'ai trouvé
que il y avait un cloisonnement entre le
département de français et le
débattement de italienne et je trouvais
que c'était dommage que on habite le
même lieu mais qu'il n'y avait pas de
communication disant intellectuels entre
les deux cultures et par quand la
tradition italienne
la tradition française sont très proches
de l'autre et donc je me suis proposé de
faire des coups des auteurs français et
italiens pour montrer les biens et les
ressemblances et aussi la différence
votre prochain programme italien et
français met en valeur par exemple de
l'année prochaine je vais faire un coup
ce bilan des lots sartre beckett lors
pirandello sartre beckett ensemble
ensemble et puis un vico et décacheté
par exemple un coup j'ai vécu et des
cartes mais vous ferez le même cours en
langue italienne et en langue française
mais c'est à dire il faut voir si il est
probable que je ne fasse en anglais pour
avoir une langue intermédiaire parce que
les étudiants des italiens qui n'arrive
pas à comprendre le français et les
français qui ne comprennent pas
l'italien si je vois que tous les
étudiants complexe et à loger leur
langue anglaise littérature italienne
capture française vous êtes le plus
européen des américains vous êtes vous
c'est vrai que vous vraiment vous
personnifiez l'europe par votre
enseignement est pas vous connaissance
c'est ça que je double tête un peu on
pourrait dire que je reste ici aussi les
états unis qui est quand même une
culture qui est fait de l'importation
des cultures et pas de mélange et puis
vous écrivez aussi un livre sur la forêt
oui ça se terminerait bientôt c'est un
livre
qui fait la folle est du point de vue
anthropologique écologique historique et
littéraire parce que je trouve que le
rapport que l'humanité avec ce lieu là
est tout à fait particulier énigmatique
et quand il faut les appeler comme
symbole là où il ya foule dans les
oeuvres littéraires il ya toujours
quelque chose de très étrange là dedans
pierre st-amand robert harrison vous
êtes tous les deux des élèves de rené
girard et de michel serres alors je vous
demander à l'un et à l'autre d'abord
qu'elles sont quelles sont les qualités
de ces deux professeurs qui a pris quand
même lors des faux ce qui me passionne
chez les deux c'est la dimension éthique
de leur travail
si rené girard il y a devant les affres
du désir mimétique une responsabilité
humaine qui est importante et chez
michel serres ilias la responsabilité
que nous avons devant les objets du
monde devant la complexité qui est le
destin de notre monde et je dirais que
le défaut à la fois de de rené girard et
michel serres c'est qu' il dise des
choses beaucoup trop importante pour
garder un air tellement joyeux l'iphone
mais c'est à dire gilles alma appris que
nous ne sommes jamais les hauteurs de
nos propres désirs
ça c'est important michel serres par
coop m'a appris comment parler
finalement des choses même et d'en
sortir de la voiture du langage qui
passe du langage et du langage et
le défaut je ne sais pas l'explication
ils ont la passion de l'enseignement
tous les deux passions dix ans à sion
qui nous ont inspirés d'une façon et
vous ont marqué tous les deux très bien
que profondément voyez très profondément
alors monsieur comme ça un défaut mais
je me dirais qu'il faut mais il ne
laisse pas des clients les deux très
reconnaissant au système universitaire
battons tous constitués des grandes
choses les etats unis qui est admirable
par sa puissance par son immensité mais
par la liberté qu'ils offrent
oui ah bon vous êtes en train de faire
l'éloge de les menacer
oui mais pensez que c'est une bonne
chose que les universités américaines
soit en perpétuelle concurrence non
seulement pour les professeurs mais
aussi pour les élèves les étudiants
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de bon système
intellectuel mais je veux dire tous les
systèmes en leurs défauts et la
concurrence pour les publications pour
les étudiants si vous voulez il ya
abouti à beaucoup de tricheries
n'importe qui vous dira même en physique
en mathématiques 99% des publications
sont très très mauvaise redondantes
l'espagne est sans intérêt je pense
quand même que le système des
publications et le système du marché et
le meilleur n'est ce pas dans la mesure
où ils restent où ils restent intactes
oui je ne veux pas sous-estimer la vie
culturelle des universités françaises
mais je pense que les universités
françaises aujourd'hui sont un peu trop
lié au système fonctionnariat il ya
quelque chose d'assez syndicaliste
ici à quelque chose de plus dur voyez
alors le on essaye de reconnaître la
qualité et la qualité s'achète et
qualité des prêteurs qu'elle était
dépité validé et oui c'est vrai que les
étudiants note les cours des professeurs
et oui nous avons deux longues à la fin
du trimestre nous leur donnons des des
feuilles des formulaires qu'il remplisse
où ils vous donnent des notes et les
notes exactement comme nous les notes
ont ils sont plus sévères et
l'administration tient compte de leurs
notes
oui et non à mon stade le plus encouragé
professeur louis brochen professeur ça
peut être très grave et ça peut être
très mauvais à mon avis parce que ça
crée des complexes des traumatismes et
surtout ça peut créer de la démagogie
autant le système du fonctionnariat créé
des messieurs les ronds de cuir autant
ce système là peut créer une espèce de
démagogie aboutir à des formes de
totalitarisme larvée royal ans je ne
prône aucun système et san francisco
sonore de deux grandes universités
stanford est une université privée
et puis berkeley qu'est d'autres côté
quitté l'université d'état qu'est la
meilleure des deux elles sont réputées
toutes les deux elles sont réputées tous
les deux à ce temple
si vous voulez pendant longtemps il n'y
a pas de doute que barclays sur le plan
international sur le plan américain
était plus important que c'est en fait
aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de gens qui
dirait que c'est un frêle et au dessus
de barclays ou peut-être s'en est enfin
là bien meilleur moral
c'est une morale va le moral de
1000mercis 6 par exemple fait que
l'année dernière et les deux dernières
années je crois c'est un peu la bête tu
as envie pour la première fois en
fanboys c'est à dire en dons financiers
fait à l'université pendant l'année oui
alors ça c'est très fort d'arriver à
battre fed qui est une
oui mais la salle en puissance oui mais
ça c'est le fric encore
stanford l'éternel compétition sportive
mais aussi compétition intellectuelle
non
le sipri aura le plus de plus noble
le plus de membres de l'académie
nous on remporte deux victoires dans les
laboratoires et sur le stade et plus
dans les universités et plus les
universités sont riches
cette zone morel et plus elles
investissent dans la recherche dans les
milieux mais cela
votre dernier clou en perte à sion oui
mon dernier course était un cours qui
étaient sur heidegger sur sartre sur
levi strauss et c'était un cours un peu
sur le high de guerre et les la double
influence les deux grandes vagues et
votre prochain cours
alors écoutez je n'enseigne pas jusqu'au
mois de décembre au plus tôt 5 janvier
bon touché un cours soit six au sexe
l'âge ou plus de cours jusqu'au 5
janvier
oui vous avez une vie formidable quand
même ici non mais c'est vrai oui bah non
parce que j'enseigne de tri mais sur 3
wii et la joue sûrement troisième
trimestre et je ne vais pas enseigner le
premier trimestre et vous aller
enseigner quoi partir du challenge et je
vais enseigner un shakespeare
pendant l'hiver et au printemps je vais
enseigner un cours à 250 étudiants de
première année sur le 19e et 20e siècles
cours est ce qu'on appelle les humanités
mais ce court sur shakespeare la coince
idées avec la publication prochaine d'un
nouveau livre sur shakespeare
oui je suis en train de faire un livre
et je le fais depuis pas mal d'années
sur shakespeare qui va paraître en
anglais en français en même temps
j'espère pour qu'on voulait écrire en
anglais
je vais écrit sur ce mail anglais oui
c'est la première fois que vous faites à
la libre en hongrie
j'ai fait beaucoup d'articles mais alors
c'est là aussi on a crié à la trahison
d'un ordre et olives en français
voulaient que vous avez écrit verdun
aurillac section shakespeare en même
temps je en train d'écrire en français
vous écrit un livre en anglais sur
racines là ce serait mais c'était que
vous allez de nouveau analyser vos
thèmes qui ont fait votre renommée c'est
à dire la violence parmi mille dix le
bouc émissaire dans les pièces de
shakespeare je m'efforce montré que non
seulement shakespeare et mimétique
jusqu'au bout des ongles si j'ose dire
mais qui les théoriciens de la chose
c'est une espèce de proust en ce qu'il
fait des commentaires et que la plupart
des passages très controversé
shakespeare que beaucoup de gens
considèrent comme incompréhensible je
vais les expliquer en montant que c'est
de la théorie mimétique avant la lettre
il ya qu un homme qui ait jamais vu ça
c'est james crise et alors il ya un
chapitre sur joyce
livres pour montrer que joyce est le
plus grand critique shakespearienne n'a
pas été pris au sérieux derrière dans
ulysse chapitre sur shakespeare qui est
gigantesque comme la vie quand vous
publiez vos livres qui leur prêtent plus
d'attention sont les français sont les
américains maintenant sur le plan
universitaire ces américains sur le plan
public c'est votre public et je pense
qu'en france c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux c'est ce public de jambes qui a
toujours existé le public de sainte
beuve
n'est ce pas le fait que le lecteur
cultivé que le médecin l'avocat en
france a envie de lire des livres de se
tenir au courant de l'habilité vous
rendez pas compte en france
à quel point c'est unique à la france ça
existe un peu l'italie ça existe un peu
mais à l'angleterre par exemple il ya
beaucoup de culture des gens j'étais
libre vous pensez pas que des rené
girard des michel serres ce sont des
hommes du professeur en voie de
disparition dans le dans les universités
américaines futur on a toujours dit ça
je pense qu'il va y avoir des
transformations
je veux dire que par exemple des
départements de langues modernes ont
peut-être se transformer et jamais je
pense quand même qui aura il y aura de
la suite parce qu'il ya des étudiants
enthousiastes et il ya des gens
intelligents et quand même la mairie qui
a depuis les années 50 la mairie quand
même se cultive l'amérique se transforme
lentement mais elle se transforme
qu'est ce que c'est là ce bâtiment là
aussitôt une affreuse faut bien oui qui
n'est pas très belle et qui a été et qui
appartient au département de science
politique et qui contient le fond du
président en faveur
et lorsqu'elle a été construite les
étudiants se sont amusés à l'appeler la
dernière élection nous monsieur
président à propos des directions si
j'osais à michel serres c'est que ces
personnes qui si il n'y a pas de flirt
on ne voit personne aucun garçon en
brèche et aucune fille
on a même l'impression qu'il ya pas de
sexualité sur ce campus est vrai que le
corps californien enfin le corps qui est
pratiqué ici c'est le corps gymnastes le
corps musclé le corps musclé et en
général il n'ya pas d'étudiants qui ne
fasse pas de la course du sceau du
water-polo etc
c'est une sorte de religion de la
gymnastique et du sport
et d'autre part il ya une autre religion
c'est le corps pur c'est-à-dire pas de
pharmacie pas d'alcool etc
vous voyez mais alors du coup le corps
plaisir le corps qui mange le corps y
boit le corps qui fait l'amour est un
peu passé passé sous silence
veillez il ya une sorte de pureté
général n'est ce pas qui est tout à fait
caractéristique que de la mérite
alors qu'en france le corps du plaisir à
beaucoup d'importance qui s'y est alors
là l'habillement de tous et il est
pratiquement je dirais pas qu'ils sont
en uniforme
oui il n'ya pas de coquetterie par
exemple les filles n'ont rien c'est
juste un américain ne regarde pas ne
regarde pas l'autre en train de passer
riez cette espèce de regard critique
collectif que les français ont les uns
envers les autres n'existent pas ici de
sorte que de quelques manières que vous
soyez habillez-vous passée un peu
inaperçue alors ça un avantage et un
inconvénient
l' avantage c'est que on jouissait d'une
liberté extraordinaire mais
l'inconvénient c'est que vous êtes un
peu solitaire
ouais ces espèces de collectivités que
donne lors le regard de tous sur chacun
n'existe pas alors il ya à la fois
liberté solitude et l' inverse dans les
civilisations européennes ou latine
c'est qu'on est moins libre mais on est
finalement plus solidaire voilà c'est ça
leur est différent c'est à dire que est
ce que les étudiants français se sont
heureux dans un système dont celui ci
oui parce qu'ils jouissent de la
différence c'est à dire que pour eux ils
jouissent d'une liberté d' à lure kiné
qui n'est pas tout à fait celle de
l'europe
cela dit ça se paie par une solitude
réel
l'absence de regard ou l'absence de le
problème qui distingue les deux cultures
c'est la relation entre des hommes il ya
un certain type de relations européennes
ou l'at-il il n'existe pas d'ailleurs
vous êtes vraiment latin parce qu'il
n'arrêtait pas même à vélo de haut
servir de vos doigts de se casser la
gueule santé gesticule
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
original mcginnis canadiens de langue
anglaise joli coup en tennis aime jouer
de la guitare classique
mon sujet et bien scellé métaphore
religieuse dans la littérature française
précisément chez nerval pour les
réponses et bien bas ce qui m'intéresse
enfin le sujet c'est l'âge comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer mais ce qui
m'intéresse en particulier c'est que ces
auteurs écrivant dans un monde de plus
en plus sécularisée ont chacun un
répertoire intérêts sable de métaphore
religieuse
je pense que cela pose également des
questions sur le statut du sacré dans le
monde moderne à savoir qu'est ce que le
sacré quand il n'est plus que métaphore
vous voyez un jeu je parle de ses
auteurs la par rapport à notre classe et
qui lui écrivait dans un monde qu'ils
étaient 20 qui sortait du sacré mais qui
en était quand même beaucoup plus proche
et qui essaient girard qui vous a
suggéré cette peine vous c'est vous même
qui l'avait finalement je pense que
c'est venez chirac qui me l'a suggéré
mais maintenant que je j étais déjà
disposé en arrivant ici c'est
effectivement disposé par quoi c'est à
dire que je en arrivant à ce temps fort
je m'était proposé de décrire une thèse
sur l'ancien testament est à l'oeuvre de
proust mettons enfin disons plus
précisément le rôle des allusions
biblique et avis est au testament terre
dans l'oeuvre de proust et il voulait
abandonner les noms je pense que le
sujet est quand même semblables je n'ai
pas changé le sujet ah si je l'échangé
mais c'était à portée d'un sujet enfin
cessé dans la même foulée comme hier
michel serres m'a montré un texte de
deux feuillets et demi vous avez rédigé
sur le thème du feu qui est absolument
magnifique
magnifique par l'écriture les alors le
feu c'est un des thèmes évidemment de
michel serres mais vraiment j'ai
beaucoup apprécié l'élégance de votre
écriture sa précision est vraiment vous
même vous avez une maîtrise totale de la
langue française
vous êtes une aimable tu t'es dans le
style à ce moment là je pense oui mais
là c'est ce que j'avais fait c'était un
aparté du thème du feu j'avais également
ma famille en opposition les thèmes de
la sagesse et de la folie vous donner
raison à gérer gérard de nerval fou sur
le roi salomon sage géré en sachant ce
qui est vain qu'elle était le rapport
véritable entre le temps et le feu alors
que ça le monde lui l'ignorait vous
prenez quand même pas des sujets faciles
oui ça peut le paraître mais je pense
que c'est peut-être ça la gageure
maintenant parce que l'académie n'est
quand même pas ce qu'elle était il ya
cent ans
et nous qui dans son dans les boîtes de
nuit et qui écoutons le rock
je pense que fin c'est si nous étudions
des sujets auxerre c'est quand même
d'une autre manière que des gens le
faisait il ya cent ans
[Musique]
l'arginine essonne californienne
assistant de machines à sous qui n'est
pas faisable et un marathonien
je suis né à san francisco mais s'était
élevé à los angeles tout pêcheur venu à
san francisco et que font vos parents
mon père et agent de compéter mobilières
et ma mère une fin de fin de ménage il
comment avez vous été amené à choisir si
tenté que vous ayez choisi la langue
française c'est à dire que quand j'avais
5 ans j'étais dans une école où on
commençait à parler français comme ça et
alors j'ai continué à parler français
pendant toute ma carrière de jeunesse et
à l'âge de 14 ans je suis allé au lycée
en france
annecy annecy voilà vous êtes resté un
an
ah non voilà j'y restais avec une
famille c'est à dire donc que la langue
française et la littérature françaises
nous ont séduites natation voilà et vous
passionne
oui voilà alors je regarde le thème de
votre thèse c'est l'alcool et
l'alcoolisme dans les rougon-macquart
d'emile zola vrai bon pourquoi emile
zola
je vous aimais beaucoup le 19e siècle
oui c'est à dire que j'ai choisi le 19e
siècle en fonction des réseaux là parce
que les livres de zola c'est de dire le
coma car il était toujours mes livres de
chevet quoi pendant ma jeunesse tout ça
alors quand leur peau la taz est arrivé
j'ai dû choisir
alors je me suis dis pas j'aimais bien
ceux-là alors j'ai beaucoup aimé vous
bientôt l'heure parce qu'il part ça m'a
beaucoup enseigné celui 19e alors du
point de vue de l'histoire voilà
et aussi je
je voyais un lien avec ces temps ci avec
aujourd'hui et avec mes expériences
aussi penser aussi que zola décrit
souvent des sociétés en crise et que
aussi l'amérique est en crise aussi les
correspondances entre oui voilà surtout
par rapport aux troubles et et la cool
je concentre sur la poule à
et voilà la grande question que ce que
cela pose dans ses livres à mon avis
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on se trouve
dans une telle société
pourquoi on se drogue voilà voilà
d'autres d'où le thème de l'alcool et de
l'alcoolisme voilà pourquoi est ce quand
ça cool is mais c'est quand même curieux
d'avoir choisi ce sujet qui est quand
même très particulier dans l'oeuvre de
zola est ce que parce que c est ce que
vous avez choisi ce sujet de l'alcool
égoïste pour des raisons je dirais
personnelle familiale et que vous
demandez à zola de répondre à des
questions que vous pensez
voilà oui ce sens ça fait partie de mes
expériences et sa 2e expérience et donc
de vos interrogations très personnel
c'est quand même étonnant de se dire que
là une californienne d'aujourd'hui de la
fin du xxème siècle qui qui interroge
zola et zola lui apporte les réponses
qu'elle souhaite
ouais
[Musique]
j'ai glissé comme bo basé sur vos
parents vous prête une invitation non
fleurs dans les geôles il bon alors à
die ou steam vous êtes vous êtes unique
italienne de naissance mais vous avez
vous été en france vécu longtemps à
paris oui jusqu'à présent j'ai vécu
treize ans la roquette et vous à vos
parents d'émigrer pourquoi pas ce que je
cherchais du travail sont des ouvriers
ils rêvaient de l'amérique et en quinze
ans après est ce que vous avez
l'impression de n'être plus du tout une
vingtaine mais une américaine
non pas du tout au contraire je me sens
tout à fait européenne c'est vrai oui
c'est des coups et pourtant regardez
vous faites jogging et des jolis
l'aurait alors je dirais plutôt que je
suis européenne est un peu américaine
j'ai fait du jogging mais je fume encore
et je vais dans les cafés voilà c'est ça
mais il n'y a pas un refus quand même
chez vous des merlus amis de l'art de la
vie américaine simplement vous essayez
vous intégrer oui j'essaie de m'intégrer
mais je ne peux quand même pas oublier
les premières très années de ma vie sur
les américains de votre famille ce
seront vos enfants oui voilà alors
qu'elle pèse avez vous choisi j'ai
choisi l'image habitat dit dans la
littérature française donc à travers
qu'est le vrai scandale chateaubriand
madame de staël et george sand autrement
dit il est choisi un sujet qui est une
sorte d'hommage à vos deux racines
italiennes et françaises et le quai
lequel les images des écrivains français
donnent de l'italie de cette époque je
dirais qu'ils en donnent plusieurs les
deux jeux j'ai pensé que les deux
nations étaient comme les soeurs latine
on les appelle souvent et cela les
soeurs latine
et il me semble que les français voient
l'italie comme la soeur aînée souvent à
à cause des ruines de l'histoire romaine
en italie et comme la soeur aimée et
malheureusement la soeur humilié aussi
quelques voix ben voila je gagne bien
agréable j'ai pas l'habitude mais c'est
très agréable fergeau bing avec vous et
puis il y avait que stendhal broustal se
vend bonne compagnie
[Musique]
yann promis vous êtes keller région de
huy qui était alors dites-le pour les
français parce que le minnesota est
juste à côté de tes grands lacs
c'est juste à gauche mais vous venez
d'une ville ou d'un peu d'un village
village la population est donc un tout
petit village jeu ce sont des
agriculteurs mais q comment avez vous
été amené à choisir la langue française
dans ce petit village
je crois que c'était une sente aventure
que j'avais envie d'aller en france à
mon université il y avait le programme
d'échangés entre nous c'était une petite
ville en france qui s'est pas ouvert et
juste je suis passé il ya dix ans et
qu'elle t'aide quel sujet de thèse avez
vous choisi un péché j'ai choisi ce
sujet de l'image du paysan dans la
littérature française comme simple on
chez balzac et je voudrais étudier un
des effets de la révolution sur cette
image présent mais alors c'est
intéressant puisque vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que votre père est fermier
donc c'est presque un hommage à votre à
vos parents à travers ce sujet nommage à
vos origines parce que c'est un mot qui
est en train de disparaître et demande
agricole a beaucoup changé
c'est très mécanisée
nous avons par le contrat social laisser
le lien qui nous rattache au monde
laissez le lien qui relie le temps qui
passe et coule au temps qu'il fait celui
qui met en relation les sciences
physiques et les sciences humaines le
droit et la nature la politique et la
physique le lien enfin qu'ils adressent
d'autres langues aux choses muette
passive obscures qui aujourd'hui en
raison de nos excès reprennent voix
présence activités lumière nous ne
pouvons plus les négliger peut-on
pratiquer dans nos attentes inquiète une
religion dirigeante du monde
c'est à l'émergence de ce nouveau et
troisième temps que je vous convier ce
soir je vous remercie mes deux fois par
an donc un stanford pour deux séries de
le sonder chaque fois c'est combien le
sang c'est mon contrat porte sur cinq
semaines et je fais une leçon de deux
heures par semaine et à chaque fois j'ai
comme sujet du cours le livre que je
suis en train d'écrire un général et
vous avez publié il ya quelques semaines
chez bordas un gros volume dont vous
êtes le directeur c'est un ouvrage
collectif intitulé éléments d'histoire
des sciences vient donc il est né d'une
certaine manière oui si oui dans les
trimestres qui ont précédé j'ai fait
comme cours ici même dans la salle où
sommes les deux chapitres que j'ai
rédigée et même l'introduction ou la
préface à ce livre là éléments
d'histoire des sciences c'était un titre
qui paraît modeste
pourquoi pas carrément une modeste
relativement parce que éléments en effet
c'est les choses élémentaires mais
éléments c'est aussi le titre de clide
éléments des mathématiques que voulait
réellement de géométrie et le titre du
groupe à qui alors c'est un titre à la
fois modeste mais étant donné les
citations ou les références que ce titre
peut avoir c'est aussi un petit peu
prétentieux alors quelle est l'équipe
que vous avez dirigé constitué de
généralement disent plus rien des
sciences mais il ya aussi des
un professionnel il y à des
mathématiciens des informaticiens et
j'ai surtout cherché des spécialistes
assez pointue de question qu'on me
l'egypte mais la mésopotamie ainsi je
suis un ouvrage comme ça s'adresse à qui
s'adresse en général au public ce qu'on
appelle le grand public cultivé
je n'ai pas la peine d'être très très
spécialistes mais tout de même il faut
avoir un intérêt bien précis pour
l'histoire des sciences si tu es bon
donc on peut pas faire toute l'histoire
des sciences pour lui il faudrait des
centaines de collaborateurs
mais vous faites vous consacrer 22
chapitre à l'histoire de ces séances
et vous appelez ces chapitres des
bifurcations qu'est-ce que ça qui est
bien on a beaucoup discuté au départ
comme en vrai ce livre est le premier la
première évidence qui se composait à
nous c'est qu'il était impossible de
faire la totalité des sciences dans la
totalité des temps pour la totalité des
sommes dans la totalité de l'espace ce
qui reviendrait à mettre dans un livre
toutes les bibliothèques c'est
impossible
c'est donc une encyclopédie qu'on a
évité de faire donc on a invité de
ferreux l'histoire globale et les
sciences nous valent et on s'est posé la
question qu'est ce que l'histoire des
sciences qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dans
l'histoire des sciences
alors on a à la suite de beaucoup de
réunions beaucoup de discussions non
polémiques et de polémiques parce qu'on
n'avait pas tous les mêmes idées sur la
question on a choisi les questions
principales
par exemple quand la science est elle
née nous ne savons pas vraiment il ya
des discussions là-dessus est elle née
en grèce est elle née en egypte et l de
la mésopotamie et elle n'est en europe
au xvième siècle c'est tout une question
qui n'est pas encore résolu et nous
avons fait le chapitre sur cette
question et vous apporter les pièces et
on apporte des pièces sur la porte des
jugements et ainsi de suite
deuxième question est ce que l'on
appelle science toujours la même chose
c'est un concept qui évolue par exemple
au moyen-age on appelle la théologie une
science maintenant en attendant de ne
plus appeler la théologie une science
par conséquent on a fait de nouveau une
chapitre sur la question de savoir
qu'est ce que la cia l'ancien site fille
chaque participant à ces éléments
d'histoire des sciences est l'auteur de
deux contributions et de grossir moi je
sois là vous avez fait alors là c'est
très savants le
le début de la géométrie en grèce parce
que c'est un problème très important et
ensuite paris 18 cents c'est à dire le
portrait de ce que peut être la science
ou la révolution française
oui alors ça c'est évidemment
passionnant puisque c'est le
bicentenaire vous montrer que la
révolution française c'est pas seulement
la sphère des politiques ou des
philosophes des lumières mais c'est
surtout la sphère des oui on peut dire
que la règle des savants oui oui des
savants j'ai même tendance à dire après
avoir beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question que la révolution a été faite
par les savants et peut-être un peu
exagéré être un peu exagéré mais nous
qui sommes historien des sciences nous
avons envie de dire à nos collègues
historiens
n'oubliez pas que les grands noms qui
sont tout à fait citer le plus souvent
dans la révolution comme par exemple
lazare carnot qui est au comité de salut
public
on ne sait jamais que c'est le plus
grand mathématicien de son temps
géomètre l'inventeur de la topologie par
exemple condorcet qui est reconnu comme
conventionnelles dont on sait mal qu'il
a été un grand statisticiens mécaniciens
etc
à la place la grande tous ces gens-là
participe à la révolution
bailly le maire de paris bailly le maire
de paris et le meilleur astronomie
longtemps il est historien de
l'astronomie et pour finir un géomètre
qui vers les années 1780 8 proposait
l'académie des sciences la solution d'un
problème de géométrie plus haut qu'on
n'arrivait pas à résoudre et qui
désormais est connue sous le nom de
solutions de mon appart et voilà un
géomètre qui devient empereur
vous avez quand même oublié au passage
un autre inventeur de la révolution qui
a une grande renommée c'est docteur
guillotin
oui c'est vrai que depuis l'abolition de
la peine de mort n'a oublié sur
l'invention majeur
alors pour terminer michel serres sur
cet ouvrage si je vous demandais comme
ça tout à trac
quels sont pour vous les trois plus
grandes découvertes scientifiques comme
ça en répondant rapidement là je dirais
volontiers premièrement de l'invention
de la géométrie en grèce certainement
deuxièmement l'invention par galilée de
la physique moderne
certainement aussi et troisièmement le
grand démarrage de la biologie
contemporaine avec la découverte des
microbes par pasteur et je réponds cela
parce que je suis absolument persuadé
que pour comprendre moment donné il faut
comprendre la science de ce temps pour
comprendre notre temps il faut qu'on
rendre la science de notre temps et on
ne peut pas comprendre la grèce sans
mettre en jeu l'extraordinaire
jaillissement cas était une invention
des mathématiques
on ne peut pas comprendre l'arrivée des
temps modernes sans qu sans se référer à
cette extraordinaire arrivée de l' objet
scientifique d'observation et
d'expérimentation il y en eu comprendre
écrit en temps modernes
si on ne faisait pas allusion à la
médecine et la biologie aujourd'hui
michel serres a du temps time
mais le temps weather et frisquet un
étudiant américain qui a eu michel
certains professeurs et à la sorbonne et
un steward me disais qu'à la sorbonne en
dehors du court il voyait michel serres
passé dans les couloirs on n'est qu'à
stamford
il est tombé déjeuner avec six plongées
l'inconscient rires
favorisé par la vie sur le campus il y
as entre étudiants et nibali soeur un
commerce très sympathique tout à fait
l'obligation peuvent faire les vrais que
vos petits chasseurs s'y prête
particulier après deux cas avec humour
et le très évidente bonnion de l'ue
négation et il disait ça dans une sorte
de conférence et à ce moment là un
étudiant qui t'a fait au fond répondu
ouais ouais
[Rires]
ça ne semble pas avoir oublié sa mort ce
type de relation qu'on peut avoir avec
vous c'est un peu particulier mais ça
tient aussi au nombre
lorsque improvisera 12 étudiants il peut
avoir des relations très facile avec
chacun d'eux lorsqu'il en a 200 voire me
il est impossible d'avoir des relations
sable alors ça d'abord une affaire de
nombreux puis ensuite si les faire des
espaces les universités françaises en
génération dans des villes de sorte
qu'après le cours les étudiants s'en
vont chacun chez soi ou à la
bibliothèque et ses magnifiques dans
l'univers si américaine il ya une vie de
campus donc l'étudiant et l'enseignant
vivent pratiquement la journée ou la
demi-journée dans le même espace et par
conséquent des jeunes ensembles se
rencontrent peuvent se voir ainsi de
suite
donc c'est d'avoir une affaire de
nombreux espaces c'est ça la vraie notre
grande différence
d'autre part il ya peut-être une offre
qui est intéressante
ce que ce qui caractérise le français
c'est l'esprit critique n'est ce pas est
ce qui caractérise l'américain c'est
l'esprit positif je dirais volontiers
que l'américaine dit oui dans le
français du nom et par conséquent
l'amérique est un pays de la bonne
volonté et la france est un pays de
l'esprit critique
de sorte que dans l'enseignement un
professeur français dira le plus souvent
la critique à son étudiant ce qui ne va
pas et un professeur américain dira
volontiers tu es bon tu peux réussir et
il tire vers le haut
l'homme le pousser l'autre le tir et
après 20 ans d'enseignement dans les
deux pays un pied d'un juge à côté de
l'atlantique
je m'aperçois que c'est peut-être ce qui
caractérise le plus la différence entre
les deux qu'est ce que tu préfères
je crois que les deux ont les avantages
aux à première vue le plus intéressant
c'est de tirer l'étudiant vers son
meilleur mais il ya aussi dans la
critique systématique une sorte de
volonté exaspérés de perfection alors je
crois que la technique américaine permet
aux jambes les plus nombreux d'arrivée
tandis que la technique française est
presque plus élitiste c'est à dire on en
tire moins mais ils sont peut-être plus
excellents du doigt parce qu'ils sont
plus sculptée par la critique
grosse winslow vous êtes vous de quelle
région les états unis à du nordeste
etats-unis 2 et pourquoi vous faut
choisir où la langue française aussi
d'une question difficile je pense parce
que moi je j'adore parler le français
aussi le français s'est dit mon meilleur
sujet à l'école et puis je vais jouer
vos était doué j'étais petit c'est très
dur mais je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
j'aime beaucoup la vie intellectuelle
spirituelle français oui c'est à dire
vers quelle hauteur au à travers à les
auteurs classiques aussi gâteux j'aime
beaucoup le côté un peu mystique
vous aimez les mystiques oui les
mystiques pour ça que vous êtes suivait
le cours de rené girard a oui alors en
dehors de la langue française la
littérature française des mythes
français qu'est ce que vous aimez dans
notre pays qu'est ce que jean tiberi
j'aime beaucoup chanté en français
vous aimez chanter oui non vraiment je
chante oui j'ai prévenu le cas de la
lune ou bien des opéras au jazz opéra
disparates mais aussi le 20 mai mais
j'aime beaucoup massenet vous pouvez
chanter maçonné oui maintenant oui oui
vraiment oui par exemple le rêve des
grillons très bien très bien la crainte
je fais tu rêves où nous sommes doit se
le mort tu as a man roma je viens de
faire alors quel est votre travail en
dehors de chanter parce que l'eau chaude
mois noble et j'ai comme ça mais je veux
que vous travaillez c'est bon alors
coiffé d'un oui ça c'est la cloche de
oui mais c'est ce monde c'est le temps
linéaire c'est pas mal nous sommes dans
le temps cyclique
je m'intéresse beaucoup à la différence
entre les deux temps du temps et le
temps mais ça c'est l'affluence de
michel serres exact oui et je voudrais
voyage et aux îles du pacifique du sud
parce que je m'intéresse aux mythes
tahiti de la littérature française scelf
racing est dû à l absence est absolument
que vous faites 16 à 10
exactement je fais pas ça pourquoi
pourquoi telle tiges convoite américaine
aussi parce que il y avait un sondage
très récemment dans l'express sondages
d'opinion dans laquelle enfin les
français on a posé des questions
français kelly laurent quel endroit
quels lieux est ce que vous voulez aller
magique magic exactement pour évadés la
peau les vases ion et on a choisi un
pourcentage extraordinaire a choisi
haïti ça continue dans le mythe dans les
rêves français
vous êtes tous les élèves volontaires de
rené girard et de michel serres et ma
première réaction et se demandaient
pourquoi vous avez choisi de recevoir
leur enseignement
quels avantages y trouve et vous quels
bénéfices intellectuelle en retirez-vous
caisse et j'espère qu'ils ont attiré
beaucoup de bénéfices qu'est-ce qui peut
m'expliquer ça alors qu'il veut me dire
un choix personnel par exemple pourquoi
girard pourquoi ces équipes qui peut
répondre tout de suite c'est possible de
bloquer et voilà j'ai une question pour
eux michel serres et rené girard dans
rome est dédié à rené girard qui a
accueilli michel serre aux états unis
d'après la dédicace et dans le bouc
émissaire ou les choses cachées on
trouve très souvent des traces des
changes entre rené girard et michel
serres j'aimerais qu'il nous dise ce qui
les rapproche
alors moi je dirais que je dirais deux
choses peut-être je dirais d'abord que
il ya le millier de la france ça c'est
pas une réponse théorique
mais avec michel je retrouve bizarrement
certains espéraient montpellier et
l'autre d'agen moins de l'avignon à vis
à vis ni au pardon je trouve certains
aspects de mon enfance je me trouve je
me surprend en train d'utiliser des
termes utilisés ma mère ou ma grand mère
et je n'ai pas utilisé depuis 50 ans et
je les essaie avec michel et 9 fois sur
10 celui sur deux quand même
impressionnistes michel les utilisent ou
les connais ou connaît une version
légèrement différente de deux
provençaliste mais sur le plan
intellectuel alors je dirais qu'avec
michel ce que j'ai encore un c'est
peut-être une certaine attitude
vis-à-vis des idées michel ne crois pas
aux méthodes et moi je crois pas non
plus je crois que le vrai savoir se
situe toujours c'est toujours des trucs
qui tombe entre des compartiments déjà
fait et tout ce qu'on est dans des
compartiments déjà fait tout ce qui est
déjà là n'a plus beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est pas parce que avoir une méthode
c'est ne rien trouver
je dédicacer mon livre harnais mon livre
de romain rené simplement parce que la
théorie de rené m'a permis de faire le
rapport entre eux l'histoire des
sciences et l'histoire des religions ce
qui m'a toujours passionné
c'est le rapport qui peut exister entre
l'histoire des sciences et l'histoire
des religions et et rené m'a beaucoup
aidé pour pouvoir faire sur ce que vient
derniers lacets à ses compartiments qui
ne serait pas très intéressant c'est ce
qu'on met entre départs heinze a
toujours été la passion de ma vie parce
que je suis scientifique d'origine et
littéraire de formation secondes et j'ai
toujours été comme rené impatient d
irriter parfois par les découpages
universitaires concernant les
spécialités une vie est très courte
aidez moi c'est ça qui me frappe moi je
crois qu'il faut 25 ans pour développer
une unité alors mais là avec mes cheveux
n'ont pas le même rythme non michel est
fulgurant j'espère moi je suis toujours
là où michèle dix mois j'enfonce un clou
et qu'est ce que tu dis je crois qu'il
ya des sangliers des renard rehab toi tu
un sanglier musiciens renard les
spécialistes en juillet cette norme qui
s est un homme s'était c'est une espèce
bien particulière qui creusent toujours
dans nokia qui creuse tandis que le
retard est une espèce particulière qui
explore un peu partout et je crois qu'il
ya deux sortes d'esprits c'est vrai dans
toutes les spécialités
si vous voyez les mathématiques aussi il
ya des gens qui ont eu une idée une
théorie qu'ils ont approfondi leur vie
durant et au contraire ceux qui
travaillent en latéralement et qui
explore des espaces de plus en plus
larges quitte à faire la synthèse à la
fin mais vous êtes contents vous d'être
renard et pas sanglier c'est ma nature
et et vous êtes contents d'être sanglier
par renard compte enfin je pense
je pense que je suis fatigué en
puissance mais en même temps ça cache
des fois des je regrette beaucoup de
pathos
enfin alors je comprends pourquoi ce
département français et des étudiants
heureux parce que ils auront tous ces
élèves tous ces étudiants ont à leur
disposition est un renard est un
sanglier est au fond 2 termine en jeu
cet entretien par une sorte d'hommage à
la fontaine voilà le renard
[Musique]